so your son is now four and I hear he
corrects you when you're speaking
Spanish is this true oh yeah he's four
he's four okay he's flew because he's
he's his first language is Spanish I
didn't grow up speaking Spanish yeah
because we live in Mexico City I was
just shooting in Spain he's super fluent
and he corrects me all the time and he
does it with like attitude he's like
disgusting Mom I'm like what you're for
easy easy I'm disappointed yeah he's
like so disappointed in my Spanish it's
way easier it's so cool that he's
learning at such a young age it's easier
yeah you know dialect all of that is
easier to pick up then so he sounds very
wise for his age he's super smart okay
he's brilliant
myself so both of our mamas were
teachers were you a good student
but I felt like I had to be in like my
mom she was like in the time in the
moment she was so annoying because she
would like go to the school for
everything and she would go and ask my
teacher why is she gonna be I read this
it was like an A and yeah my daughter
needs to be in that class and she needs
to be on this track and so to have a mom
like that advocate for you at school is
super life-changing and important
looking back now so God bless all the
teachers in the world yeah um yeah so I
ended up being a great student because
because she made me that's amazing my
mom's so angry right now at home yes
yeah I was not a I think the only thing
that kept me in school was the Arts like
I just I I love learning I'm like an
avid learner I love reading I love all
that I just didn't like I just think and
especially having kids now yeah people
like to learn differently like you know
we learn different and it's very hard
for me to sit still in like a desk and
like I'm learning we still learn that
way is weird I know it's just it I'm I
it was just very hard for me for like
that many hours in a day to be like yeah
a worksheet it's hard for most kids yeah
still and especially like technology has
disrupted so many Industries every
industry Health Care yeah how we buy
stuff I mean everything but yet it
hasn't quite just corrupted how we teach
in the classroom yeah you should have it
should which is interesting because you
thought covet would have changed out a
tiny bit just because we all were on
Zumba anyway glad that's not still
happening
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
I'm going home